sofía es uno de los nuevos pobres en
francia enfermera de profesión ella y su
marido están sin trabajo
tengo un bebé de dos meses
evito todo tengo miedo con él cobit al
menos venimos aquí una vez por mes y nos
dan esta ayuda es mejor que nada
tras los confinamientos la demanda de
ayuda alimentaria es un indicador de la
pauperización de la población en francia
un millón de personas más que en el 2019
viven bajo el umbral de la pobreza en la
ong seguro popular hay más público pero
también más voluntarios algunos incluso
sin trabajo como emanuel por la crisis
sanitaria sólo ellos pueden manipular
los alimentos que proponemos a la gente
los productos y ellos pueden elegir si
quieren llevarlos o no entre el comienzo
de la crisis sanitaria y ahora
constatamos entre un 30 y un 35 por
ciento más demandas de lo que es
considerable históricamente recibimos
familias un poco de gente sola y un poco
de estudiantes ahora tenemos incluso
gente que trabaja y estudiantes
es el caso de julia vive con su hermano
en un pequeño departamento en parís
tenía un trabajo de fin de semana en una
joyería pero como está cerrada perdió
ese ingreso en su primera visita a este
banco de alimentos
nos vengo para comer y comer variados
sobre todo verduras y pescado que no
compramos porque son caros si es sobre
todo para comer y comer correctamente yo
tenía un poco de prejuicio pero me están
acompañando muy bien y eso me hace bien
el gobierno lanzó una convocatoria de
proyectos para modernizar los mecanismos
de lucha contra la pobreza las
asociaciones tienen hasta el 15 de enero
para presentar propuestas